I'm mad at Joel I'm a [ __ ] owner I
don't [ __ ] want to clean I've been
here 12 hours it's unacceptable I do
want to approve Gordon Ramsay were hung
about me being a [ __ ] idiot [ __ ]
dumb and dumber
[ __ ] scoundrel wanker [ __ ]
whatever British [ __ ] terminology
that [ __ ] wanker has to say across
from the [ __ ] different mom guy but I
do respect him drink
you guys all know I like party but by
any I neither lying down you know I'm
gonna go play poker and Reno later
tonight sleep listen to the [ __ ]
music how does anyone ever get to sleep
miss her sound Jesus Christ
that's crazy frogs asses
right here right now
[Applause]
cries
as this this doesn't make sense
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's gotta be a cause a room
somewhere
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh [ __ ] here we go hey I have a walk-in
to clean I've been here I want to go get
that clean it because it's number one
right now this is soon this is your just
a joke they're partying and I'm upset
and we're just I don't know they're
party Joel I've said it everything
that's going on and I want it this is
I'm just upset about
thank you for two minutes by your guests
I want to go clock I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go clean the walk-in
just walk off like that I'm gonna go
clean the walk which figures you know
why why acting like a [ __ ] jerk
because I'm upset I was [ __ ]
unacceptable on the air zone except the
[ __ ] walk in with a [ __ ] black
mole why don't you do something about it
hey I was i if I